évidemment la turquie ne cesse de
multiplier les agressions contre ses
propres alliés de l'otan notamment et la
liste commence à être longue
maintenant on en est venu à des attaques
personnelles contre le président de la
république c'est à dire contre
l'ensemble des français dans une période
particulièrement douloureuse puisque
nous venions de connaître ce dramatique
attentat et donc nous demandons et je
vais demander dans quelques instants
en interrogeant le gouvernement sur ce
sujet quelle mesure effective
le président de la république et surtout
le gouvernement compte prendre à
l'endroit de la turquie pour arrêter
cette escalade qui n'est pas simplement
une escalade verbale
car parmi les les nombreux faits que
l'on peut reprocher à la turquie il ya
bien sûr les incidents qui nous oppose
en mer orientale
il y a bien sûr le chantage aux flux d
d'immigrés que la turquie nous menace
régulièrement de libérer mais maintenant
il y à l'encouragement et la
participation de la turquie dans le
dramatique et terrible conflit du haut
karabagh au lieu de jouer le rôle d'une
puissance qui travaille pour la paix
elle apporte un soutien armé à
l'azerbaïdjan dans l'offensive qu'ils
mènent contre l'arménie est donc
véritablement ça ne peut plus continuer
comme ça vous pensez à quelles mesures
effectives contre nature qui est bien
écoutez moi je vais en je vais en
proposer une tout à l'heure au ministre
je garde évidemment la primeur de ce
propos pour la séance
mais je pense qu'on peut faire quelque
chose et cesser de se réfugier dans des
déclarations alors qu'en fait monsieur
erdogan s'appuie sur la faiblesse de
l'europe pour avancer systématiquement
et je vais aussi demander au
gouvernement bien sûr de plus plus de
solidarité de la part de nos amis
européens que je trouve assez discret
sur ces sujets vous trouvez pas qu'il ya
une union européenne autour d'eux
emmanuel macron dont je n'en suis pas
persuadé il ya des messages très forts
de la part de l'autriche et de quelques
autres mais j'en attends plus de nos
principaux partenaires et voisins
merci beaucoup